alors tu reviens sur ta vie euh tes
petits délits ta jeunesse tes déboires
judiciaire moi aussi sur tes rencontres
tes passions tes poèmes ce que tu fais
des poèmes aussi oui je sais on te
découvres sous un angle complètement
différent dans ton livre tu as fait ce
livre tout seul non avec c'est avec
Stéphane c'est ça voilà
exactement ouais c'est lui qui est venu
te voir ouais il t'a dit ouais
j'aimerais bien écrire ta vie
tu as kiffé il y a plusieurs qu'ils ont
venu me voir mais j'ai jamais voulu
faire pourquoi parce que ça m'intéresse
pas et puis il y en a plein qui un jour
ben comme lui je connais puis du coup
j'ai fait avec lui quand j'ai eu des
problèmes pourquoi c'est toi tu lui
raconter tout ce que tout ce qui était
alors je dois avouer tu avais envie de
raconter quoi
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il y a de plus en plus d'émissions de
télé sur les gitans en ce moment il y en
avait une sur M6 il y a pas longtemps
est-ce que vous trouvez qu'on donne une
bonne image les gitans à la télé il y a
beaucoup de de trucs qui existent pas
quoi
[Musique]
les gens ils
connaissent pas la vraie vie donc tu
parles de tes déboires judiciaires
pourquoi tu es allé en prison
pour les bagarres bagarre
vous nous raconter
j'en ai fait plein
[Rires]
quoi
c'était sérieux donc ah oui oui non mais
regarde pas comme ça regarde
c'est quoi alors c'est quoi la c'est
quoi la première bagarre qui t'a amené
en prison la première la première
bagarre j'avais 15 ans
et puis il y en a une bagarre et je me
suis fait égorger là
donc toi tu as fait combien d'années de
prison 20 ans
à chaque fois pour des bagarres
j'ai fait 30 ans de boxe je regrette
tout ça tu regrettes les bagarres ou pas
ah oui parce que j'ai perdu ma vie j'ai
passé en prison donc je mesure j'ai pas
vu grandir mes enfants j'ai oui
il y a des trucs qui que j'ai fait je
regarde pas ça mais le truc oui et en
prison tu t'es mis à rédiger des poèmes
sur quoi surtout mes enfants c'est vrai
ils disent quoi
[Musique]
que je pourrais dire est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment s'il vous plaît merci merci
alors ça c'est ton livre
Joe la victoire véritable histoire de
Joe Lopez c'est vrai que c'est une
légende mais c'est vrai je l'ai fait que
je l'adore
exactement ou pas
c'est vrai qu'on se connaît depuis
longtemps jaune et il sait que comment
il sait que je l'apprécie beaucoup c'est
vrai que c'est un frérot et Joe tu as
écrit des poèmes et c'est vrai que tu
est-ce que tu veux que je lises un de
tes poèmes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu me laisses deux minutes là
Cyril il vient de me dire un truc rigolo
il a jamais lu son livre ben non parce
qu'il a raconté
c'est normal mais pourquoi les gens
alors quand même avec ces histoires là
parce que je suis quelqu'un je pense que
je suis connu dans les gens du voyage
parce que comme j'étais un bagarreur
était devenu une légende parce que tu
aimes j'étais connu voilà et puis les
gens qui me connaissent pas ils me
voient ils croient que je fais deux
mètres 140 kg je crois que je suis moi
ça m'arrive de discuter avec des gens
qui disent que un salopette
parce que je veux dire c'est que les
gens que moi je côtoie qui connaissent
je Lopez de non non ils disent qu'ils
connaissent en fin de compte c'est moi
Lopez mais lui justement je connais pas
d'accord et qui va embrouiller Bernard
Montiel en fait moi
il faut savoir c'est je vous dis il a
refusé des sommes énormes pour faire des
télés je lis non mais c'est vrai tu as
refusé des sommes énormes
après c'est l'émission c'est connu avec
le clash qui a eu avec
bien sûr là après
connu mais à l'époque il y a pas les
réseaux comme maintenant et donc on va
convoqué pour venir aux émissions j'ai
jamais été nulle part la seule maison
c'est Cyril sinon j'ai jamais été chez
moi
que chez moi ou pas
tu connais cette chanson il ne faut pas
me ressembler
ta chanson préférée
je me trompe ou pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est que c'est la chanson que
j'aime bien parce que comme j'ai grandi
loin de mes enfants et quand j'ai vu mes
enfants maintenant j'aurais chanté même
que parfois tu as l'impression qu'elle a
été écrite pour toi
je sais et les années ont passé je ne
t'ai pas vu grandir c'est vrai mais je
n'ai su jamais su et aujourd'hui te
voilà presque un homme est devant moi je
pense à ton fils Tony
va bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]
à mes enfants à Blandin Joe
qui s'appelle
tu restes avec nous ça me fait plaisir
moi quand tu es là tu es content de me
voir moi je suis content de te voir
attends vous connaissez je Lopez
sur youtube il y a quelques années il y
avait des vidéos il y avait des clashs
interposés je crois que les bagarres
voilà des bagarres et ça fait des
millions de vues histoire et c'était des
vraies histoires
comme c'est vrai ils parlent ils croient
que c'est des jeux mais c'est pas des
jeux on les avait des vidéos oui on est
on les a passés
la moitié de sa vie en tôle et que il
pense à ses enfants et qu'il a pas
grandi avec ses enfants et c'est aussi
important comme message c'est pour ça
effectivement
résilience
entre-temps j'ai eu des problèmes là
donc j'ai tapé un cancer et j'ai manqué
de mourir mais c'est de ma ville et du
coup ben j'ai fait slip pour mes
petits-enfants et là aujourd'hui là ça
va
parce que moi je suis les gens de moi et
mes enfants ils savent pas qui je suis
là ce que je dis là il s'en va à peu
près qui je suis en tout cas merci
d'être là bonjour tu sais que on t'aime
ici